[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend in allen die lage ist
verfahren kompliziert und hochgefährlich
die reaktionen sind besorgt alarmiert
sie sollen zumindest ein zeichen setzen
das brandenburger tor in berlin heute
abend in den farben der ukraine
solidarität mit der großen zahl von
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer die in der
deutschen hauptstadt leben zumindest das
zuhause rüsten sie für einen krieg der
ukrainische präsident kündigt eine
teilweise mobilmachung von reservisten
an und er will den ausnahmezustand
verhängen russland zieht seine
diplomaten aus der ukraine ab die fahnen
an den gebäuden sind bereits eingeholt
und den moskau nutzt der präsident den
feiertag dort für ein ganz eigenes
zeichen wie christian senn zeigt
es ist ein bewährtes ritual für wladimir
putin kranzniederlegung an der
kremlmauer am grabmal für den
unbekannten soldaten
hier wird an die sowjetischen gefallenen
im zweiten weltkrieg erinnert heute am
tag der vaterlandsverteidiger mit
besonders viel symbolik und putin sagt
heute russland sei immer offen für einen
direkten und ehrlichen dialog aber
die interessen russlands die sicherheit
unserer bürger sind für uns
bedingungslos deshalb werden wir uns
weiter entwickeln und armee und marine
verbessern um sicherzustellen dass ihre
effizienz steigt damit sie mit der
neuesten technologie ausgestattet sind
während putin in moskau dem russischen
militär huldigt wird an der frontlinie
in der ost ukraine weiter geschossen
für die menschen die hier leben gehört
das wieder zum traurigen alltag
in den rebellengebieten sieht man
militärfahrzeuge ohne offizielle
hoheitszeichen wie damals 2014 als
russland die krim annektierte auf sie
zum russischen militär gehören unklar
heute pressekonferenz von
separatistenführer puccini gemeinsam mit
dem putin vertrauten tucek der kreml und
die separatisten sprechen jetzt eine
sprache fossilien überschreitet die
russische regimes in bonn
im moment gibt es hier keine russischen
truppen und vor diesen ereignissen haben
alle internationalen beobachter
einschließlich der osze wir nach ihnen
gesucht aber sie haben sie nicht
gefunden
was die zukunft betrifft ob es möglich
ist dass russische truppen hier sind es
ist möglich
dass der aus moskau angereist chuck wird
nach russischen truppen gefragt hier
gibt es keine russischen truppen jetzt
jetzt wann kommen sie sage ich ihnen
sport
putins verwirrspiel offen zur schau
gestellt und in der ukraine heute eine
neue cyber attacke die webseiten
verschiedener ministerien und
bürgerportale nicht erreichbar und
präsident salewski fordert einmal mehr
internationale unterstützung für sein
land wir verteidigen uns selbst mit der
hilfe unserer partner
aber wie die ukraine sind es um die
sterben werden die ukraine braucht
sicherheitsgarantien klar konkret und
jetzt weil wir sicher sein wollen dass
wir die menschen und unsere häuser zu
schützen können
und während die ukraine mit der
kriegsangst leben feiern die russen in
moskau im militär
auch mit kleinen paraden die heimat im
herzen die spielzeugwaffe in der
handtasche der panzer wird zum
spielplatz mit dem militär kommt man
hier schon sehr früh in berührung
man muss sich von kindheit an dran
gewöhnen ein mann soll sich selbst sein
vaterland und seiner liebsten
verteidigen können sie sollen die
soldaten von morgen sein in russland
wird das militär den menschen in form
einer fröhlichen folklore nahe gebracht
das nachbarland ukraine ruft wegen der
massiven bedrohung durch die russische
armee heute den notstand aus denn für
die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer ist die
bedrohung und die angst vor einem krieg
ganz real und keine show
geld regiert die welt und russisches
geld ist nicht nur in moskau und sankt
petersburg zu hause sondern vor allem
hier london eaton square im volksmund
mittlerweile der rote platz russlands
oligarchen haben in den besten bezirken
der britischen hauptstadt unfassbare
summen investiert sie kaufen immobilien
meist versteckt hinter wilden firmen
konstrukten sie bezahlen anwälte
treuhänder und gewieften pr firmen
gleich mit dazu die sich dann um das
richtige image kümmern sie kauften lange
auch unkompliziert die
aufenthaltsgenehmigung und irgendwann
den britischen pass in london kann alles
und jeder gekauft werden sagt einer von
ihnen die milliarden haben die
oligarchen aus russland auch zugang zu
höchsten kreisen britischer politik
ermöglicht und gerade da hat keiner mehr
gefragt wo das viele geld eigentlich
herkommt jetzt soll sich der wind drehen
in london grad premier boris johnson
verspricht hart durchzugreifen aber das
haben andere schon gesagt und sind immer
eingeknickt ja in
hallwil staatsmännisch kite und
entschlossenheit demonstrieren der
zuletzt ja arg ins schlingern geratene
premierminister großbritanniens in der
aktuellen fragestunde heute im parlament
verteidigte boris johnson die am tag
zuvor beschlossenen sanktionsmaßnahmen
gegen russland
da wird noch mehr kommen wir werden den
handel mit russischen staatsanleihen
stoppen und russische firmen daran
hindern sich geld zu leihen
konkret sind seit gestern die britischen
vermögenswerte 3er im erdgasgeschäft
tätige putin treuer milliardäre
eingefroren worden ebenso die von fünf
russischen banken doch kritiker im lande
sind sich einig das ist bei weitem zu
wenig und zu spät
seit vielen jahren ist london
anerkanntermaßen ein spielplatz reiche
russen eines der beliebtesten spielzeuge
fußball clubs der premier league nach
der champions league hat der russische
milliardär roman abramowitsch mit seinem
fc chelsea vor kurzem nun auch die welt
klub meisterschaft gewonnen
und da wären vor allem noch die sehr
beliebten londoner nobel immobilien laut
der anti korruptions organisation
transparency international befinden sich
fast 150 londoner häuser im wert von
zirka 1,8 milliarden euro im besitz von
russen die entweder unter
korruptionsverdacht stehen wurde eine
direkte verbindung zum kreml haben oder
beides
zumindest die vergabe der sogenannten
goldenen visa aufenthaltsgenehmigungen
und spätere einbürgerung gegen
investitionen ab 2 millionen pfund soll
jetzt eingestellt werden allerdings
entsprechende maßnahmen hatte die
damalige ebenfalls konservative
regierung bereits 2015 angekündigt
seither haben aber weitere 200 russische
millionäre die britische
staatsbürgerschaft erhalten nur sieben
anträge wurden abgelehnt
wenn putin die ukraine auseinander
nehmen sollte und seine kollegen freunde
daraufhin aus london weggeschickt werden
und in moskau beim hängen müssen werden
die auf ihn wütend sein das wird er sich
zweimal überlegen
doch macht großbritannien nun wirklich
ernst ähnlich wie beim gerangel um nord
stream 2 setzt russland darauf dass der
eigene wirtschaftliche schaden den
westen zurückschrecken lässt in london
verdienen viele mit am russischen geld
zudem haben boris johnson und seine
konservativen bei all dem ein
glaubwürdigkeitsproblem
ich denke ich dass der regierung hier
alle mittel ausschöpft sie haben nicht
den wirklichen willen das problem zu
lösen
nicht zuletzt weil sie parteispenden von
reichen russen die in verbindung mit
putin stehen angenommen haben die
sollten sie zurückgeben
konkret bezieht sich der
oppositionsführer auf 2,75 millionen
euro die johnston stories aus russischen
quellen bekommen haben sollen man sieht
trotz aller scharfen worte in sachen
sanktionen es wird nicht einfach sein
die geld waschanlage london grad mal
eben so abzustellen
es gibt sogar eine stadtrundfahrt für
touristen entlang an multi millionen
willen der russischen superreichen in
london die sogenannte kleptokratie tour
insider sagen dass europa mit russischem
geld überflutet wurde hat nicht russland
verändert sondern den westen in dieser
situation lohnt es sich mal genauer auf
die zuschauen die die europäische union
jetzt auf ihre sanktionsliste setzen
will es ist eine illustre und sehr
bemerkenswerte liste anne gellinek ist
unsere europa korrespondentin sie war
auch lange für uns als korrespondent in
moskau kann also aus beiden richtungen
darauf gucken guten abend alle
was fällt denn wenn man auf diese liste
guckt als erstes und als besonders auf
es fällt auf dass das verbindende
element diese auf einzelpersonen die auf
der liste stehen die freundschaft die
bekanntschaft mit wladimir putin ist
bisher hatte sich die europäische union
bei erstellung von sanktionslisten er
auf die politisch verantwortlichen
gestützt also leute die mit gestimmt
haben bei der krim annexion oder
parlamentarier die jetzt die
volksrepublik 'nen anerkannt haben jetzt
aber geht die eu darüber hinaus und
robbt sich sozusagen an den engsten
freundes- und beraterkreis von wladimir
putin heran da ist zum beispiel der
russische verteidigungsminister auf
platz 1 der gehsteige ein mann der putin
seit 20 jahren in verschiedenen
funktionen begleitet und der ein enger
freund es die beiden gehen manchmal am
wochenende in sibirien jagen dann
greifen wir uns doch vielleicht noch mal
so ein zwei weitere personen raus auf
dieser liste neben dem
verteidigungsminister und dem stabschef
der auch drauf steht das konnte man
jetzt vermuten ist auch dabei maria
sakar war die sprecherin des
aussenministeriums das ist ja zunächst
mal ein bisschen ungewöhnlich eine
pressesprecherin
oder ist sie mehr alle
ja sie ist viel mehr als eine
pressesprecherin sie fällt regelmäßig
aus der rolle einer sprecherin und vor
allem einer diplomatin heraus seit
wochen trommelt sie spricht davon dass
es in der ost ukraine einen genozid also
ein völkermord völkermord geben den die
ukrainische regierung vorüber an der
russischsprachigen bevölkerung im
donbass und sie bereitet damit nach
auffassung der eu sozusagen den
propagandistischen boden für einen
einmarsch russischer truppen in der
ukraine vor und dann
rego schien ein geschäftsmann aber auf
besondere gebiet
er hat den spitznamen putins koch denn
er war einmal tatsächlich koch in putins
lieblingsrestaurant in sankt petersburg
hat dann ein catering unternehmen
gegründet das dann zufällig die
russische armee und fast alle russischen
schulen belieferte und ist so zum
milliardär geworden dann hat der
geschäfte mit dem russischen
verteidigungsministerium gemacht und
eine privatarmee die sogenannte
söldnertruppe wagner gegründet die in
den letzten jahren in libyen in syrien
in mali und auch auf der krim im einsatz
war prejean steht bereits auf einer eu
sanktionsliste aber weil er nämlich das
waffenembargo in libyen unterlief mit
seiner söldner truppe jetzt aber hat die
eu noch mal nachgelegt und ihn und seine
gesamte familie auf die sanktionsliste
gesetzt jetzt heißen ja sanktionen an
nicht mehr nach europa reisen dürfen
gelder und vermögen sollen eingefroren
werden wenn man aber bedenkt dass die
wahren eigentümer ja gerade bei diesen
investments sorgfältig verschleiert
werden wie effektiv kann der dieses
sanktionssystem am ende überhaupt
funktionieren
da muss man schon ein paar fragezeichen
setzen denn wir reden hier ja von
schwerreichen oligarchen und leuten die
sich die von dem system seit vielen
jahren profitieren und die haben nicht
nur villen in südfrankreich oder band
hauses in london wie wir gerade gesehen
haben sondern die haben natürlich auch
genug geld um sich die sogenannten
goldenen pässe zu kaufen die es auch in
der europäischen union gibt also malta
bulgarien und zypern sind dafür bekannt
dass man eine eu staatsbürgerschaft
kaufen kann wenn man nur genug geld in
dem land an legt außerdem werden sie
sich natürlich schon länger überlegt
haben ob sie ihr geld noch in eu banken
deponieren oder ob sie nicht vielleicht
die schweiz oder andere steueroasen
wählen um ihr geld dort in sicherheit zu
bringen anne gellinek zdf brüssel
herzlichen dank für diese analyse heute
abend
und dann gab es heute abend sanktionen
der usa gegen die betreibergesellschaft
der gaspipeline nord stream 2 nach
deutschland die betreibergesellschaft
gehört dem russischen staatskonzern
gazprom ex kanzler gerhard schröder ist
chef des verwaltungsrats el mati wissen
für uns in washington immer heißt dass
sanktionen jetzt möglicherweise auch
gegen den ehemaligen bundeskanzler
anders gefragt könnten ihm die usa das
konto sperren
also aus dem weißen haus hören wir dass
gerhard schröder diesmal nicht betroffen
ist das könnte vielleicht noch kommen
aber zunächst mal richten die sanktionen
sich gegen nachdem zwei ag also das
unternehmen und dessen chef matthias
warnig der landet auf einer liste die
nennt sich sdn liste special special
agent des international das sind all
jene deren konten deren guthaben hier in
den usa wenn sie welche hier haben
gesperrt werden und amerikanischen
firmen und us bürgern wird verboten mit
diesen personen auf dieser liste
irgendwelche geschäftsbeziehungen zu
haben normalerweise stehen auf dieser
sdn liste des finanzministeriums
ich sag mal auch drogendealer und
terroristen mit drauf für die
us-regierung ist das was an sanktionen
jetzt beschlossen worden ist heute noch
einmal im grunde genommen das
todesurteil für die nord stream 2 wenn
bleiben ja putin nicht seine truppen
wieder aus dem osten der ukraine ab
zieht wenn er nicht die anerkennung
dieser separatisten gebiete zurück nimmt
dann so geht man hier davon aus wird
nord stream 2 niemals ans netz gehen der
sprecher des außenministeriums sagte
vorhin diese elf milliarden dollar
investition sei dann nichts anderes als
ein stück stahl auf dem meeresgrund
immer vielen dank und so fiel in dieser
sendung zunächst zu diesem wichtigen
thema jetzt zurück nach deutschland zu
uns in die innenpolitik wo die
regierungskoalition versucht ein problem
in den griff zu bekommen
das ja allen gerade sorgen macht hanna
es geht um die energiepreise die seit
monaten immer weiter steigen aus diesem
grund soll es jetzt entlastungen geben
darauf hat sich am abend die ampel
koalition geeinigt unter anderem soll
die ökostromumlage wegfallen und zwar
bereits ende juni also ein halbes jahr
früher als bisher geplant außerdem soll
die pendlerpauschale erhöht werden auf
38 cent ab dem 21 kilometer geplant ist
zudem ein einmaliger sonderzuschuss von
100 euro für erwachsene hartz 4 bezieher
und empfänger von grundsicherung und
soll einen sofort zuschlag für arme
kinder von monatlich 20 euro geben ab
juli
es ist ein neu geschaffenes amt auf
bundesebene
die spd-politikerin riem alaba radovan
wird erste anti rassismus beauftragte
die 31 jährige ist bereits
staatsministerin für migration
flüchtlinge und integration im
kanzleramt und wird nun beide aufgaben
ausüben alaba radovan will künftig die
maßnahmen der bundesregierung gegen
rassismus koordinieren sie kündigte
einen nationalen aktionsplan gegen
rassismus an und plant außerdem ein
beratungszentrum für betroffene
es ist eine personelle neuaufstellung
der bayerischen landesregierung mit
blick auf die landtagswahlen 2023 hat
csu-chef söder sein kabinett umgebaut
gleich drei minister posten wurden neu
besetzt es gibt außerdem einen neuen
staatssekretär und auch der
csu-generalsekretär wechselt hier folgt
der bundestagsabgeordnete stephan mayer
auf den bisherigen generalsekretär
markus blume der wiederum soll
wissenschaftsminister im kabinett werden
und wir schauen auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen und da zeigt sich die bundesweite
sieben tage instanz ist erneut gesunken
laut robert-koch-institut liegt der wert
inzwischen bei 1.200 78,9 und auch bei
den neuinfektionen gibt es einen
rückgang im wochenvergleich gemeldet
wurden 209 1052 neue fälle das sind fast
11.000 weniger als vor einer woche
299 todesfälle kam hinzu
die auslieferung disco-hit 19
medikaments packs sowie in deutschland
hat begonnen das gab der pharmakonzern
pfizer bekannt die tabletten sollen bei
menschen mit vorerkrankungen das risiko
von sehr schweren krankheitsverläufen um
knapp 90 prozent senken die
bundesregierung hatte ende letzten
jahres eine million einheiten des
medikaments bestellt
es geht um respekt vor ehrlicher arbeit
sagt der bundesarbeitsminister als er
kommentiert was heute das bundeskabinett
passiert hat und ab oktober gelten wird
der gesetzliche mindestlohn steigt dann
auf zwölf euro pro stunde respekt vor
ehrlicher arbeit wer würde dem
widersprechen
zumal laut gewerkschaften etwa 6,2
millionen menschen profitieren mehr als
16 prozent aller beschäftigten dem
arbeitsminister wird es auch um die
erfüllung seines großen
wahlkampfversprechens gehen aber die art
wie er das tut außerplanmäßig und an der
dafür eigentlich zuständigen kommission
vorbei sorgt auch für kritik andreas
huppert hat mehr
wolle mir steht vor den toren magdeburgs
stadtbekannt die bäckerei schäfer und
hier gab es heute ministeriellen besuch
regentropfen vollkornbrote und
kuchenstücken auch der arbeitsminister
zu bestaunen der hatte sich die location
ausgesucht um hier medienwirksam die
mindestlohn erhöhung auf 12 euro zu
verkünden
davon werden über sechs millionen
menschen in deutschland profitieren vor
allen dingen frauen wie hier diese
bäckerei und viele beschäftigte in
ostdeutschland
es ist so viele auch eine lohnerhöhung
bis zu 22 prozent der herr pr-termin
zeigt wie wichtig gerade für die spd der
mindestlohn ist im wahlkampf ein
zentrales versprechen von olaf scholz
die grünen waren auch dafür bei den
liberalen hielt sich die begeisterung in
grenzen der mindestlohn von 12 euro
schaffte es in den koalitionsvertrag und
heute ins kabinett die lohnfindung ist
aufgabe der tarifpartner und insofern
ist es jetzt tatsächlich etwas was die
gefahr in sich birgt dass immer wieder
staatlicherseits in diese lohnfindung
eingegriffen wird und ich glaube es wäre
schlecht wenn zukünftig immer vor wahlen
ein überbietungswettbewerb was den
gesetzlichen mindestlohn anbelangt es
geben würde seit 2015 gibt es in
deutschland den mindestlohn er startete
bei 8 euro 50 aktuell liegt er bei 9 eur
82 steigt im juli auf 10 eur 45 um dann
im oktober auf 12 euro angehoben zu
werden
ungefähr 60 prozent des mittleren
einkommens und danach werden die
weiteren erhöhung schritte wieder
aufgabe der mindestlohn kommission sein
dass es gerechtfertigt menschen mehr
verdient haben weil sie mehr in der
tasche brauchen als der bundestag 2014
den mindestlohn beschließt beschließt er
damit auch dass die höhe eben nicht vom
staat sondern von der sogenannten
mindestlohn kommission festgelegt wird
im gremium aus gewerkschaften
arbeitgebern und wissenschaft mit der
einführung der mindestlohn kommission
hat die politik sagt die
mindestlohn-kommission sollte
mindestlohn festlegen jetzt soll der
deutsche bundestag den mindestlohn
plötzlich festlegen das ist ein
vertrauensbruch und wir werden uns
insbesondere gegen diesen
vertrauensbruch während die arbeitgeber
auf die barrikaden gehen finden die
gewerkschaften nichts verwerfliches an
dem einmaligen staatlichen eingriff die
arbeitgeberverbände der arbeiten
zunehmend aktiv daran dass tarifverträge
gar nicht zustande kommen und deshalb
ist es eine notwehr reaktion des staates
den gesetzlichen mindestlohn so
anzuheben dass
armutsfeste löhne entstehen mindestlohn
kommission hin oder her am ende zählt
dass mehr in der tasche das finden sie
auch in der bäckerei schäfer
wir gehen auch irgendwann mal in rente
und möchten eigentlich nicht in die
altersarmut rutschen und keine
grundsicherung beantragen müssen nach 45
oder 47 arbeitsjahren das wäre natürlich
traurig dann die zwölf euro mindestlohn
sind megaschön also wirklich grund sich
millionen darüber freuen neben der
freude der mitarbeiter hier in
wolmirstedt über den künftig höheren
mindestlohn nimmt der arbeitsminister
auch noch was handfestes mit feines
graubrot nämlich geschnitten für drei
euro
so wir bleiben noch moment in der
wirtschaft auch ein sehr wichtiges thema
jetzt mit hanna es geht um kinderarbeit
um fehlende sicherheitsstandards oder
auch mangelnden umweltschutz bei
zulieferfirmen solchen praktiken will
die eu kommission jetzt ein lieferketten
gesetz entgegen stellen und unternehmen
stärker in die verantwortung nehmen
heute wurde dazu offiziell ein
gesetzentwurf präsentierte und valerie
haller an der frankfurter börse der ist
deutlich schärfer als die deutschen
regelungen was kommt da genau auf die
unternehmen zu ja also die unternehmen
sollen die lieferkette ja auf mögliche
verstöße kontrollieren und zwar in beide
richtungen es geht also um zulieferer
und abnehmer bei verfehlungen fallen
dann bußgelder anja und die europäische
vorlage dies sind sofern strenger weil
sie auch kleinere firmen in die pflicht
nimmt und damit weit mehr als das
deutsche gesetz außerdem sind die
umweltauflagen noch mal strenge das eu
lieferketten gesetz beträfe in der eu
tätigen firmen mit mehr als 500
mitarbeitern neu wäre auch dass die
opfer von verstößen von nationalen
gerichten klagen könnten und firmen
müssten sich auf die klimaziele der eu
verpflichten aus der wirtschaft kommt
kritik deutsche verbände warnen vor
einem bürokratiemonster
die vorgaben seien für viele nicht
umsetzbar und sie beklagen hohe
verwaltungskosten
gewerkschaften und umweltverbände
hingegen begrüßen die vorlage als
grundstein für mehr umweltschutz und
weniger ausbeutung die linke hätte sich
allerdings noch strengere regeln
gewünscht dass deutsche lieferketten
gesetzt das kann zunächst einmal wie
geplant kommendes jahr in kraft treten
sollte die eu aber ihr eigenes paket
tatsächlich schnüren müsste deutschland
seine regeln anpassen und entsprechend
verschärfen vielen dank valerie nach
frankfurt
und jetzt noch der blick auf die
lottozahlen von diesem mittwoch sie
lauten 5 7 11 15 24 47 und die superzahl
2 alle angaben wie immer ohne gewähr
und jetzt zurück in die 80er wer damals
hören konnte wird sich erinnern
everybody wants to work
[Musik]
und schaut
alles dieselbe band einer noch so in das
isoft können wir gerade sehr gut
gebrauchen
[Applaus]
tsv faires waren 18 jahre lang weg sie
sind zurück mit einer politischen
botschaft an eine welt die aus den fugen
scheint und sie klingen jetzt so
nicolette feiler tun
[Musik]
ihre musik ist dunkler geworden aber
unverkennbar tears for fears
[Musik]
dabei könnten die beiden heiterer sein
mit 30 millionen verkaufte alben und 40
jahren
nun unsere leben unsere schicksale sind
miteinander verwoben und ich denke das
ist gut so wir neigen dazu aufzutauchen
wenn etwas schreckliches in der welt
passiert
in einer welt die gerade aus den fugen
gerät erscheint ihr neues album nach 18
jahren funkstille sie nennen das der
tippingpoint der kipp punkt
wir haben den titel gewählt wegen des
zustands der welt eben des aktuellen
kipp punkt von der politik in den usa
bis hin zum klimawandel und jetzt können
wir sogar von der ukraine krise sprechen
und im warmen leben gerade in einer welt
in der wir uns gegenseitig nur bekämpfen
ihre songs spiegeln das seit 1981
es war die zeit in großbritannien beide
waren scheidungskinder sonstwie women in
chains klagen den elterlichen missbrauch
an
[Musik]
reckermann ein song aus dem aktuellen
album knüpft daran an
[Musik]
die saison ist von so vielen beeinflusst
vom rechten flügel in amerika und vom
aufstieg donald trumps der diese
toxische männlichkeit vertritt die ich
schon immer seltsam fand und von der
mito bewegung all diese dinge bedeuten
jetzt sehr viel vor allem wegen meiner
töchter
20 am beginn des lok don't think platz
muss diese version mit seiner tochter
[Musik]
networld übrigens sie erster großer hit
bekommt den pandemie zeiten keine neue
bedeutung
[Musik]
letztendlich leben wir 40 jahre später
immer noch in einer verrückten welt
definitiv
[Applaus]
kraftvoll und voller wehmut so klingt
das für fiat jetzt
[Musik]
er ist ein liebeslied für die sterbenden
ich habe meiner frau dabei zusehen
müssen wie sie mit einer krankheit
kämpfte und verlor es war also eine sehr
traurige zeit und das alles spielte sich
im hintergrund ab während wir uns darauf
konzentrieren ein album zu machen aber
dann kam schließlich das herz und die
seele dessen dass wir durch machten zum
vorschein
wieder die nicht krampfhaft ob des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert sein
wollen dafür aber von zeitloser größe
[Musik]
und mit diesen zeitlosen erinnerungen
schicken wir sie in den mittwochabend
gegen 0.40 meldet sich dann hier nah
sein möchte mir mit unserem
heute-journal update von uns allen an
sie einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
sogenannte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter sie schauen kurz zurück auf den
januar und es war der sechste wärmste
januar global nach dem kopernikus
datensatz aber lokal war es natürlich
relativ warm zum beispiel über europa
oder richtung sibirien hier die
temperaturabweichung deutlich größer und
richtung nordamerika deutlich darunter
also kälter trotzdem ist der januar zu
warm ausgefallen
wir schauen uns europa noch mal genauer
an hier sieht man auch in deutschland
nach osten in richtung skandinavien
waren die temperaturen deutlich höher
als normal unter februar war ja bisher
auch zu mild und mit geht am morgen
zumindest noch weiter hier wird relativ
milde luft angesaugt vor einer kaltfront
die drängt aber diese wärme schon wieder
ab schauen wir auf die nacht viele
wolken kommen auf im laufe der nacht
ansonsten klart es im südosten
deutschlands auf an der see richtung
nordsee frischt der wind aus
südwestlichen richtungen kräftig auf
stürmische böen sind dann dabei ja die
temperaturen sinken bis auf minus fünf
grad im südosten und 7 grad richtung
niederrhein morgen ist es erst einmal
trocken und dann kommt die kaltfront
weiter ins landesinnere es regnet in der
nähe der kaltfront gibt es auch
stürmische böen im südosten merkt man
wenig davon hier scheint auch die sonne
und dort temperaturen bis 15 grad in
schleswig-holstein 7 grad ja und die
nächsten tage am freitag gibt es schauer
und gewitter nach südosten hin auch
freundliche abschnitte bei 4 bis 10 grad
am wochenende wird es zwar kühler sein
aber auch sonniger ein schöner art